this week on quadriga refugee crisis do
we care enough they're fleeing
persecution war and poverty in the hope
of a safer and better life in Europe
hundreds of thousands of asylum seekers
have made the trek to Germany since the
beginning of the year
many Germans are eager to help them but
there's also been opposition and even
racist attacks can Europe find a worthy
answer to the humanitarian crisis or
will it isolate itself still further
coming to you from Berlin quadriga the
international debate your host this week
peter craven a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of quadriga coming to you
from the German capital Berlin and our
topic today is the refugee crisis and
the question we are asking is do we care
enough and to discuss that question I'm
joined here in the studio by three
seasoned observers and commentators and
I'd like to introduce them to you now
beginning with Catarina shock Walzer who
is an expert on Central and Eastern
Europe and currently an associate
professor in the department of border
region studies at the University of
Southern Denmark now Kathy Gina says
Germany has to offer migrants a real
integration program that would help the
newcomers and allow German society to
profit from what they have to offer
now we're also joined today by
Christophe on Marshall he is the
diplomatic correspondent for the Berlin
Daily dare Targa Spiegel in his opinion
there are desirable and undesirable
asylum seekers people from the Balkans
he says have no right to asylum and they
don't have the kind of professional
skills that Germany needs they should
therefore be sent home and a familiar
face here on quadriga is Eric Kirschbaum
born in New York he's a reporter who has
down the years written for numerous
dailies and magazines in the u.s. he is
currently with the Reuters news agency
here in Berlin has been for many years
and he says beyond the ugly headlines
Germans have been opening their hearts
and homes to refugees a positive note
there from Eric but I would like to
begin with christoph von marshall if i
might because earlier this week one of
Germany's leading journalists said the
following or wrote the following and I'm
quoting he said the refugee crisis isn't
just a problem for the summer of 2015 he
said it's a problem for the
21st century and he went on to say that
in the future the 21st century will be
judged according to how it treated the
refugees do you agree with that
assessment
not totally of course I can't say is
that we will not come to such a
situation but recent decades have shown
that we have times when we got mayor
more refugees and times when they are
less for example in the 90s we had
already when we had the Bosnian war we
had half a million refugees in Germany
and it went down to 120,000 200,000 at
the beginning of this year we sought its
250,000 in the middle of the year we
thought it might be half a million now
we think it will be 800,000 or even a
million please you can see that dynamics
are changing and it can go down again if
we take the right precautions and sends
the right signals we're certainly
talking about huge numbers I mean the
the UNHCR has said that there are more
refugees on the move in the world now
that's any any other time in recorded
history and over half of them are
children so a great cause for concern
and our question today is do we care
enough what's your answer to that
question initially generally we care
enough yes but we do the wrong things I
think and one of the questions from my
point of view is do we use all the
private willingness to help and all the
private abilities to integrate people or
do we think it's big government
Democrats which think well it's all the
responsibility of the government and I
think this is the wrong approach it's
the wrong perception and the wrong
approach mm-hmm
Kushina stock was did the same question
you know a massive a huge refugee crisis
staggering numbers of people on the move
staggering numbers of people coming to
Europe and to Germany do do people here
in Germany do people in Europe care
enough I'm totally agree with you I
think Germany Europe not Sumatra Germany
and German society - a lot in order to
help refugees and when we compare the
help German help with international help
you appeal and help we have to say it's
enormous health on the one hand on the
other hand
Germany doesn't recognize a difference
between refugees and sure we meet her
point system a system like in in Canada
it would be excellent in order to choose
the best the best refugees and best
people the society German society needs
and perhaps you would say it's egoistic
but on the other end it would be good
for both sides for the German society
and for people who arrived here because
if we concentrate on the whole refugees
if we concentrate at all all people
coming here and help try to help
everybody at the end turn the result not
be so excellent because it's not
possible to to help a whole society but
if we from the beginning take a decision
and decide ok with these people we would
like to deal more to help more in order
to get something from them in the future
both sides would profit so in order to
answer your question I think Germany
does in north but is not enough
strategic what do you make of that
Eric I mean it sounds to me like
cherry-picking the best people from from
societies that are already struggling
economically and bringing the best
people to Germany integrating them here
and leaving those societies bereft of
some of their you know very highly
skilled men and women I mean it's a huge
enrichment for Germany that people are
coming to Germany Germany has a
shrinking population they desperately
need more people there's some very
talented Germany all the time absolutely
he's right asylum the asylum laws and
Germany are generous and being abused by
by certain people part of the reason is
because there's no real process for for
immigration to Germany are very limited
but I mean you're right at the beginning
this is a huge problem it's going to be
a huge problem for a long long time
politicians in Germany and the rest of
the
just gradually waking up to it dragging
their feet I think they're afraid to
send signals that might encourage more
people to come but with climate change
looming refugees are going to be coming
for all kinds of reasons for four
decades to come and this is the
beginning of it this is something people
have been predicting for a long time
maybe it's coming more quickly and more
and more force than anybody thought but
it was a huge problem it's gonna be a
problem and there's no there's no real
answers nobody seems to come up with an
answer or any leadership it's
interesting that you talk about
politicians dragging their heels as you
put it because Angela Merkel was
commenting on their on the magnitude of
the crisis earlier this week and she
said that it's going to be a graver
crisis a bigger challenge for our
societies than the Greek debt crisis for
example but nevertheless you will have
noted in the way that many people have
here in Germany people have been
complaining about this that Angela
Merkel hasn't so far
visited one center for asylum seekers to
to show her presence there how grave is
that omission yeah I mean there's
criticism of her for that she hasn't
really made any clear comments we
welcome the refugees she had a chance
with a young eight-year-old girl a
refugee a few months ago that she kind
of botched that one she didn't really
show compassion a lot of Germans and the
social media got upset that she saw this
girl crying and couldn't really find a
suitable answer and it went viral I mean
during this refugee crisis I think the
best of Germany has been there and the
worst of Germany in the spring when a
lot of refugees were coming and a lot of
the refugee sentiments were being burned
it was an amazing oh it's an amazing
number of burn refugee centers be
burning a lot of foreign journalists
like myself writing about those stories
that was sort of the ugly Germany that
we thought had been put behind us 20
years ago when that was happening but
then all of a sudden this summer there's
been this huge outpouring of just
ordinary Germans going out of their way
to help refugees putting them in
shelters bringing them food bringing
them water til Schweiger this actor
helped organize toys and and and and and
it's an amazing story I mean I think as
a foreign journalist it's it's nice to
see the these good Germans coming out of
the woodwork and and and and showing
what Germany can do okay just wait a
second because because Eric has given me
the perfect intro so some pictures we're
going to see and then we'll come back
and we'll discuss this the two sides of
Germany that's one look first of all
this
the ugly face of Germany these people
feel threatened and they hate anything
foreign they're a small minority but
they're noisy ready to attack
defenseless people armed with clubs or
lighters
since the beginning of the year there
have been over 200 attacks on refugee
shelters more than in all of 2014 and
this is the nice face of Germany people
who want to help those in need their
tools
friendliness and care packages they're a
sizeable and vocal minority but they
don't feature much in the media no
European country has more asylum seekers
than Germany but is the silent majority
willing to integrate so many refugees
you were you were hoping to come in and
I cut you off a short comment if I go
and as it's my opinion too much
propaganda and we just clarify for the
people at home til Schweiger is is the
Brad Pitt of German movie acting I think
it's fair to say that you know he's not
internationally that well-known but in
Germany he's a really big deal and he's
been commenting on the refugee crisis
again he's been a bit of a lightning rod
for it though - he's one of the few
German celebrities who's come out of the
woodwork and he's been bashed in social
media just because he wants to show hey
we need to show compassion with these
people they've made that they're
struggling and let's help them and and
Germans are very good at that through
their history since World War two
millions have come to Germany and and
they've been welcomed by our German so
good at that I mean why are there other
countries in Europe that are saying keep
the keep the migrants keep the
immigrants out that's what they're
asking of their politicians and the
Germans I mean if there's one poll that
suggests that 25% of all Germans have
actually considered taking in a refugee
or offering accommodation to a to a
refugee how do you explain that
well it's our perception of our history
I mean we have been guilty of expelling
people of murdering a hundred thousand
millions of people and now we try to
learn our our part of the lessons of
history and react in a different way
that's that one thing but of course it
comes to an end the moment for example
now we have still school holidays yeah
latest at the beginning of September
school children will come to their
schools and they can't do gymnastics
sports because there are refugees living
there in the schools this will become a
practical problem the first moment when
a community will tell you well we have
close to close down the swimming pool or
something else because we just don't
have the money because the money is
going to refugees then you will have a
practical problem
therefore I think we should change our
thinking we should be much more harsher
to people who have not a legal right to
come here who are just saying well we
need political asylum but in reality is
here looking for a better economic
situation which is not bad I mean I have
my full they have my full understanding
everybody would do that but it just
means they can't take advantage of the
system and we should send them home very
quickly to send a signal to others don't
come here if that is your motivation we
should be much more comforting and
better in dealing with people who are
coming from war regions like Syria like
Afghanistan like Iraq and for those
people we really have to find a better
solution in Europe and there we have to
be much more practical we don't have to
think in this administrative ways that
well that's a responsibility of the
government and there you need just
quotas how much people the country has
to take Syrian refugees are much better
off in Great Britain if they have
relatives here and it might be that
people from Africa when it's francophone
Africa they should go to France because
they might have people from their region
over there and we Germans should take in
those who have already relatives or
people from the same region or people
from religious groups I mean Germany
takes in only half of the 800,000
refugees who are coming to Germany this
year that's the latest figure takes in
only half that's 400,000 people surely
next year according to your theory
400,000 more will come because they've
got two relatives already here they've
got communities here I mean Eric has a
fair point we have to find a better way
how to say well we need an organized
system of immigration that is a question
where we should deal in order to meet
our own interests like also catagen
assets and then we need a point system
if these are people who are coming for
more regions that is in a humanitarian
question and there we shouldn't ask is
that good for us or not these are people
who are fleeing from war and they need
to shelter that the totally different
question politicians are not a big
number Sabine the refugees from the
sorry forms of war regions this is not
the big numbers this is a very a number
which is on a similar level and set/sets
might be 1/4 of
German politicians have been talking for
decades about allowing immigration they
said this was a country of no immigrants
and it's one of the biggest countries of
immigrations in the world and they just
don't get their act together they talk
about it but the reason there's this
bottleneck of economic refugees coming
Germany there's just no mechanism for
Germans to legally come there for
foreigners to legally come here and work
here that's the problem maybe that is
something we will see happening in the
future
yeah but possibly not with Angela Merkel
and her Conservatives they've always
been opposed to Germany becoming a
country of immigration although that is
what it has become in recent years
exactly not well yes or no I mean we we
have a lot of legal immigration through
the enlargement of European Union I mean
most of the migrants from the new EU
members of central Eastern Europe are
coming to Germany of course a lot came
also to Great Britain because they
opened the labor market earlier than
others
but since Germany is the biggest country
in Cu and also with the most powerful
economy a lot of those are coming here
but we are also asking people from India
if their IT specialist to come and to
our misfortunes they are not coming in
masses we would be happy if they would
can they would come but they are not
coming in these two these two guys are
talking about controlled immigration in
some shape or form either you know you
mentioned it as well a point system or
some people yes this the desirable and
less desirable immigrants Germany as
Eric already mentioned has got a massive
massive demographic problem it's an
ageing society it has one of the lowest
birth rates in the world and has for
many years now the mayor of one German
city a man called Oliver young he's the
mayor of the central city of gossler
which has a declining population he has
said as regards refugees let them all
come we'll take them all you gonna get
right I don't think it would be right
solution let to come all refugees he has
a city which is 4,000 people fewer each
year yes but we have to be careful with
those pictures of people who welcome
refugees and immigrants it depends which
region is it and it depends very very
much on numbers how many refugees
I have done a small research compared to
a situation in Drammen a small cities
and today near small cities and in
German small citizen 400 inhabitants and
150 refugees and in in most cases in
most cases this refugees weren't welcome
and people opposed and people voted
against and didn't help as we saw in
this pictures it was the opposite
picture now in Danish small cities 150
inhabitants tones and 20 refugees all of
them were welcomed and everybody helped
why because of the small number so in
that moment people were important and
were recognized as people not the
numbers but when so many refugees
arrived in their only numbers and not
people so it's difficult to to feel
together with others if we see so many
and for this reason I think it's
important to control to control the
number of refugees and regions is that
today right because if wrong decisions
I've been taking can be a problematic
for both sides okay the one thing we do
know from the discussion so far is that
the number of refugees coming to Germany
is rising rapidly and might reach the
figure we've talked about 800 thousand
this year that makes Germany the country
in the EU that has taken in the most
refugees at least in absolute terms
Sweden has also in proportional terms
taken actually more people in than
Germany but those two countries are
bearing the bulk of the burden and the
United Nations has warned that that is
unfair and as we see now there are a
number of countries around Europe that
are doing everything they possibly can
to quite simply keep people out
if you're looking to invest in fences
now would be a good time
Europe is walling itself up for fear of
refugees the iron curtain fell here in
1989
now hungary is rebuilding its border
fence britain has effectively sealed off
the channel tunnel
so would-be immigrants are stranded near
the french port of Calais living in a
makeshift camp known as the jungle
local authorities tolerated but aid
organisations say it's a humanitarian
disaster and defences really solved the
problem anyway even in the Spanish
enclave of Malaya in northern Africa
migrants have breached the six meter
high barriers Europe seems to be
counting more on isolation and
deterrence than giving aid is fortress
Europe a betrayal of European values
that's the question Katrina is Europe
betraying its values are we now going to
all European countries start building
fences barriers and walls internally and
externally it's really terrible and
fences by by wires we know from former
times don't help to solve the problem
it's terrible reaction from Hungary to
build her such a fence and it only means
to transfer to transfer a problem to
other countries neighboring countries
there are plenty of countries around
Europe we've just seen it but I was
looking at the figure for Slovakia I'm
not sure this is reliable but it said
that only fourteen refugees have been
taken in by Slovakia compared to the
huge numbers we've beat Auburn in
Germany they have to be Christian or
something as well and it has to be
Christian they're being very very very
selective about it if we have countries
around Europe saying effectively we do
not care yeah how are we going to get a
common European policy on the refugee
question we need to sit at a table and
really come to a solution but not in
this strict mathematical matter it is a
difference whether there are countries
like Latvia or Estonia
they have already 30 or 40 percent
population not from their original
ethnicity like Russians say we should
have more understanding Slovakia Hungary
ethnicity factor in the equation think
we should just be politically a little
bit flexible and there are countries
which can afford to take more people in
like Germany with the growing economies
that's easier than in a country with a
stuttering economy like like like Greece
so we should be a little bit flexible
but of course there has to be much more
pressure for a common European solution
and my point from the beginning it
shouldn't be a big government approach
we should try to find out where do those
people come from do they have already
relative strengths somewhere in the EU
and then you should sense them there in
order that private people do the
integration work more than a government
and of course you can count these people
who are taken in into national quotas
and then those who have no relatives and
no point where to go those you can send
to other places but we should really try
to use the private villainess to help
and to integrate people it's not a gap
it's not an administrative and
government responsibility in the first
place mmm
Eric you've been observing very closely
the good Germans and the bad Germans at
work here in both cases when do what
when when is a point being reached
possibly the Berlin mayor talked about
it this week a tipping point possibly a
point where the mood changes when could
there be a point where people we're good
Germans will become bad Germans it's a
good question a tough question I mean I
think one of the big problems we talked
about now is the unfairness in the EU
that some countries like Germany and
Sweden are taking in a large number
other countries in Eastern Europe and
Britain are taking in next to none and
that's a problem it's a bit like the
euro zone crisis it reminds me the euro
zone crisis where is the leadership it
takes forever for some leadership
Germany could be a great leader in this
issue Germany has more morally doing a
fantastic job the high ground at this
point in time I would think the Germany
would try to be a little more effective
in getting France on board or getting
Britain to take a bit more the EU just
is a mess really with their policy on
the on the refugees they could barely
agree to allow 40,000 in for the next
two years I mean what is 40,000 one 800
thousand are coming to Germany alone so
it's a bit of a joke seeing the way the
EU is just dropping the ball again like
they did for the first four years of the
eurozone crisis
just got worse one can only hope that
the EU will get its act together a
little faster with hopefully some more
German leadership on the refugee crisis
before countries start pointing the
finger at each other and before the mood
does turn I'd just like to remind all of
us not just you guys but myself the
official figure as far as I can tell is
1867 people lost their lives trying to
get across the Mediterranean in the
first half of this year from January to
June the question at the top of the show
was do we care enough and you know if
you were pedantic you'd be asking who
are the we yeah the we let's take it to
be the Germans us I'd like to ask each
of you do you and to you and to you and
do I do we care enough yes I think we do
how do you manifest it how does that
manifest it we try to understand why
people are coming and we are opening
doors privately and also in a public
discussion in that way we are doing a
lot and trying to understand why these
people are coming giving them a helping
hand but we can't do it for everybody
and there are also reasons that we
should send back those who are taking
places which are much more necessary for
others at Regina Germany does enough in
comparison to other countries and you
are right it's not possible to solve the
problem alone and this is why European
solidarity is needed in order to find a
solution in order to make all
participating but profit from the
problem
oh poor erik has now got two questions
the question is are the Germans doing
enough and is there such a thing as
European solidarity these days
unfortunately very little of it I mean I
think in general people in Germany do
care a lot but you think if this has
been an earthquake there'd be a lot of
solidary immediately and it's a good
point there is and this is a crisis
happening I mean in Germany we tend to
send large amounts of money to a place
that has been hit by a natural
catastrophe Greece has been hit by
refugees arriving in course very little
arriving oK we've got to break it off
there time is running out I hope we've
given you plenty of food for thought
thank you to all three guests if you've
enjoyed the show as much as I have come
back next week and do get in touch via
Facebook Twitter by mail send
to put a stamp on it and send it to me
I'd love it just
you